[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tellement bon ça me relaxe
vous venez dans mon ban préféré en date
chemin ils disent que la vie fait pas le
moine
en général quand je vois dans des shows
c'est comme se stabilise un peu
différente
quand j'arrive dans vie dans les salles
de spectacles sa vie reçue dans tôt lors
de la pause un petit morceau de carspach
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais
facilement utilisable à le changer que
les années pour ceux qui ne connaissent
je le suis un peu moins aujourd'hui
mais très jeune je l'étais je vais
sherbrooke en esprit j'ai dans un
quartier particulièrement pauvre
j'habitais pendant plusieurs années en
fait toute mon adolescence j'ai habité
les hlm
ce qui est particulier quand on vit dans
un hlm c'est d'avoir à se vendre et à
démontrer aux gens qu'est-ce qu'on n'est
parce qu'on n'a pas en fait souvent on a
tendance à démontrer ce qu'on a parce
que ceux ci c'est fun surtout à
l'adolescence tu es tu sais pas trop qui
tenait encore alors c'est important de
démontrer ce que puis je pas bon à talon
haut surtout sur une scène mais vous
allez vivre avec ce 2e temps de ma
conférence
excusez moi mais comme pour confortable
tout le temps habituellement ceux qui me
connaissent j'enlève les souliers soeur
si je les aurai plus mais le vrai gardez
donc je vous ai remis le morceau de
kraft parce que pour me défendre de
certains qu'on parle de la façon que
j'étais intimidé c'est que j'ai décidé
de voir les gens travers autre chose que
leur personne parce que leur personne
était trop complexe et difficile de
mettre en contact avec lui de me sentir
alive
alors j'ai un trip région vers large de
king size en avoir les gens comme une
pièce de carspach c'est facile parce que
je me disais c'est une pièce de kraft
ait seul individu
c'est sa couleur c'est ce qu'ils lisent
c'est sa personnalité je vous ai remis
une pièce de corse est parce que c'est
vrai que je pensais pouvoir davantage ça
m'aurait aidé mais je vais me fier quand
même à mon jugement puis hop et vous
êtes le dire ici joué pendant le fond
dans les prochaines minutes vous parler
de ce que je suis je vais apprendre à
vous connaître
parce que je considère que plus on
connaît les gens plus on est capable de
créer quelque chose de bien ensemble
alors je vais vous parler de certaines
choses si vous vous reconnaissez dans ce
que je dis j'aimerais ça vous le vivre
kraft ait six vous voit pas vous
applaudir et moi j'adore reach j'adore
reach est poursuivi non exaucé c'est mon
poste
ok je ne combats personne d'andré
exploiter aussi avec qui ils vont
prendre un drink d'antoine important
j'adore je voulais dit laissez-moi
enlevé mes chaussons je vois tellement
plus confortable et quelques enfants
donc j'ai quelques personnes j'aime
vraiment la fin des parties
j'adore le vin quand on me dit on va
dans des événements you du 20h jusqu'au
le présent
habituellement la main ça alors j'aime
le vin mais j'adore la bière sur les
bières de microbrasseries l'heure
j'adore la vienne j'aime bien les
animaux
oui le poids le bruit ça me tape
synergies j'aime beaucoup manqué pas mal
tout seul dans ma gueule un gain que
j'en ai vu qu exemple mais j'aime les
empiler certains se trouvent ça cool
trop bruyants au jeune couple d'amis
c'est le fun on s'envoie une
chose est sûre c'est que moins en voyant
les gens travers ma pièce de casting sam
sécurisé j'ai vieilli je suis allé au
sujet je suis allé à l'université et je
me suis rendu compte en fait que j'étais
différente
next et payer en ligne je le voyais pour
si je me disais bon jeu différent je
suis pauvre c'est pas drôle mon affaire
j'en ai mangé de la soupe de match peut
vous le dire c'était quelque chose me
fait tant lanta c'est réconfortant de
manger de la soupe d'amandes somme toute
la différence fait en sorte qu'on
devient plus grands j'ai appris à
connaître les gens et j'ai encore
tendance aujourd'hui à l'hiver des gens
qui meurent sans moi c'est plus naturel
parce que je me dis j'apprends de et
j'ose espérer qu'ils apprennent deux
mois cette pierre dac article m'a permis
aussi de devenir plus humaine j'ai
étudiants travaillent avec moi j'aurais
voulu être avocate je devienne trop
pauvre je veux pas l'étudier aussi
longtemps et finalement c'est pas si
grave que ce jour dessus bien content de
faire ce que je veux je travaille à
l'unité d'intervention mobile de
l'anonyme je suis directrice de ce
groupe depuis sept et j'en suis très
fier de faire ce boulot là je dis faire
ce boulot là parce qu'encore aujourd'hui
on pose la question c'est noble ans il
vit est ce que tu fais mais dis moi
c'est quoi ton vrai métier tu
t'impliques beaucoup c'est ce que tu
fais à force je pense que j'aurai le
temps de faire d'autres choses
honnêtement c'est vraiment ça mon vrai
métier
j'ai fait de tout injectés dans des
milieux non traditionnels j'ai été
gardienne de prison très jeune dans ma
carrière c'était comme la partie je
pourrai me rapprocher du droit
c'était comme ma façon d'être là bas
j'ai aussi été représentante jeunesse
syndicats de la fonction publique du
québec
c'était particulier parce que maintenant
je fais employeurs ça a été comme un un
mix intéressant j'ai négocié des
conventions et là aujourd'hui je suis de
l'autre côté du doute idées aussi
il ya pas si longtemps il ya cinq six
ans on m'a interpellé pour moi dit
sylvie moisson que ce serait bon pour
l'anonyme de fréquenter le les gens
d'affaires de quoi tu parles voilà les
gens d'affaires que ce jeu va aller
faire sûrs justement avec les gens
d'affaires et finalement j'ai fait le
choix d'essayer
parce que c'était différent je dis je
vais aller voir et ça m'a permis de
rencontrer des personnes fort
intéressante mais surtout d'en faire
comprendre que je suis aussi un
entrepreneur travail au milieu dans le
milieu social il faut être entrepreneur
- la travailler dans le milieu social
je fais ce mot année d'exercice
travailler dans un milieu social c'est
que ça prend du temps ça prend de
l'énergie mais c'est une job comme une
autre on travaille comme n'importe qui
qui est comptable qui fait du graphisme
qui s'impliquent dans différentes routes
dans différentes missions fait la même
chose que tout le monde mais avec une
mission qui différentes
on a un objectif final qui est différent
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant de rencontrer
les gens d'affaires parce que j'ai
appris deux - et je crois qu'ils
apprennent encore aujourd'hui j'ai
appris deux et je crois qu'ils
apprennent encore de moins aujourd'hui
la pire de kraft ait en fait outre aux
seuls fans quand on parle de différentes
natures parce que si vous regardez votre
pire ce que vous avez entre les mains il
ya différentes couleurs des supports
j'avoue que ce casse-tête le site une
représentation des états unis je sais
pas si j'étais inspirée par la politique
américaine dernièrement mehdi - j'avais
pris celui là parce que je trouvais
qu'ils étaient très coloré et plus on
est différent plus diversifiée plus on a
l'impression qu'on était un tout et que
c'est complémentaire
je suis le seul qui croient à la
complémentarité que je suis de celles
qui croient que d'être tous pareils ça
devient emmerdant d'être différent ça
fait en sorte qu'on ait autre chose et
que si c'est beau en fait la différence
si on prenait le temps aujourd'hui de
s'asseoir ensemble de regarder nos
pièces de kara stade de les mettre
ensemble ça formeraient un tout chaque
fois que je me présente dans une dans un
colloque chaque fois je me présente dans
une dans une réception dans un endroit
avec des amis je suis une des pièces du
casse-tête
je ne suis pas encore fait au complet je
suis une de ces pièces là et quand on
met tout ça ensemble on crie ce qu'on
est en train de faire est de vivre
ensemble afin de créer cet événement là
aujourd'hui on est tous une partie de ce
casse tête là j'ai apporté mon manteau
ici pas pour rien bon honnêtement je les
portais tellement souvent à l'époque qui
ne portent plus maintenant il est un peu
trop grand pour moi mais vous savez
sentiment qu'on a quand on porte en
invitant vêtements trop grands
si l'inconfort convient quand on porte
quelque chose qui est trop grand pour
nous bon pour vrai je l'avais pas rêver
quelque chose de plus petit mais je
trouvais que ça m'allait faut vraiment
ça et dépôts à ma silhouette de porter
quelque chose de trop serré
alors je suis jamais quelque chose de
trop bien parce que c'est beaucoup plus
confortable finalement aujourd'hui quand
je vais dans le monde des affaires je
suis confortable je m'assume j'ai eu une
différence l'ema différents scellés je
crois productive et intéressant pour les
gens que je côtoie
l'important c'est de l'assumer ma
différence de l'assumer que mon travail
en bout de ligne younis a eu un objectif
final qui se distinguent mais qui
contribue à notre collectivité ou même
titre que chacun d'entre vous qui
contribuait par le biais de votre emploi
avec le manteau rouge porté à une
organisation ou à votre collectivité
moi je le porte le manteau trop grand
pour moi ils ne servent plus à grand
chose parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis une
pièce du casse-tête
moi j'aurais juste le goût vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui on finit en femme s'était
dit que cela et on se dit que vous avez
été une des pièces de cette journée là
et que tout le monde ensemble on proviva
la pré casting et dites vous qu à chaque
fois que vous sortez dans un événement
vous êtes une personne parmi les autres
mais avoue j'ai contribué à vous d'y
mettre l'effort que vous souhaitez
immeubles mais votre place et lille elle
est toujours là tant que vous l'assumez
vous êtes confortable le faire alors je
vous souhaite une belle fin de soirée
amusez vous bien
c'est important de s'amuser dans la vie
et au plaisir de vous croiser
[Applaudissements]